so
thank you very much before i start my
talk there is an important thing which i
have
free kinder chocolate for all of you so
take one and pass it on
this is part of my talk you'll find out
why later on
this talk is called welcome our new es5
overlords um hello i'm mike uh
i'm a node and front-end javascript
developer in london
i work on stuff that kind of acts as the
glue between github and amazon
and it's right now the end of 2013
it's a good time to talk about es5
every current browser supports es5 every
previous version of every browser
supports es5
in a couple of weeks internet explorer
11 is going to come out which means
every browser before that still supports
es5
so maybe supporting ie8 is which is the
last es3 only browser is
one of the requirements for your current
project
but maybe for your next project notice
obviously es5
maybe for your next project i8 may no
longer be a requirement so you can do
the stuff that can't be shimmed into all
the browsers
so what do we think of when we think of
es5
well there's some new methods we've got
you know array filter and reduce and all
that kind of stuff
they're convenience and we probably
ignore them because we're using
underscore
and underscore is great but we don't if
we don't
need to worry about shimming these
things into all the browsers alco will
be
shorter and a little bit more readable
if we just use what's built into the
language we all
you know specialize in
but this isn't about that this talk is
about
the magic in es5 that maybe some of you
haven't actually considered before
i've got three things to show you the
first
is let
bump that down a bit there we go the
first is some really basic javascript
um so we're in berlin and berlin is for
music
uh so we're going to see some german
bands so we've got three awesome german
bands
i'm going to iterate through them really
basic stuff
uh we're going to add a button the
button is going to go
print a little message for us um there
are two problems with this
i will anyone from the crowd want to
shout out what what the f
what either of them are
that's in there yeah that wasn't
actually what i was going for
but uh that is true what's that
yeah exactly so it's not entirely
obvious what it was
um but yeah this doesn't work there's
two problems veleska from boy is
actually uh swiss
she's not german so yeah the the second
one is when the loop is finished as this
gentleman over here was saying
band actually has the last value and
that's what the inner function sees
uh therefore it's always going to be
stuck on the last band so let's actually
try that
i have
yoink here is the code here
just move that over because it's not
quite so cropped
and we click on upper upper right and it
still says craft club and we click on
boy and it still says
craft club and when we click on craft
club it still says craft club
that's no good so we could fix it
all right so uh just to explain what the
problem is the problem is we can only
see craft club
and we don't want to do that because
felix is a poser
so let's fix it uh a common way in the
way that me and
i think a lot of my colleagues will
often fix this is we just you know we
know
javascript is a functional language we
want another scope
so we add a little iffy over here
and wrap the event listener in the iffy
and now band is updated properly so it's
a little bit of extra code
and
so second iteration
and craft club still works and boy now
works
and upper art works and yay it's all
fixed
but hold on a second the whole purpose
of adding that iffy was to get another
scope
same thing in es5 is only eight lines of
code why because the 4h gives us another
scope
um and yeah we also
have to we can emit a whole bunch of
statements from the start of the for
loop
uh we don't need a index variable
because we just want the value we're not
we don't really
we're not really concerned about the
index that's actually the difference
between 12 lines of code and eight lines
of code now think about how many for
loops you have in your app
you know if you're just iterating over
an array is there really any reason
if you really have to support es5 or you
can use es5 shim
this is one of the things that is
shimmable the rest isn't
is there any reason to be writing that
rather than that
so my personal opinion is the the
standard uh
functional for loop is a much nicer fit
for javascript and there's really no
reason to be to be
doing this this big old long stuff in
2013.
so it's a third less code by lines it's
a further reduction if you actually look
at statements
it looks nice you know upright boy
graphical for each function band like
really simple
functions are a more natural fit
cool so that that's good let's let's do
this for more things we reiterate over
strings and get the characters within
them we iterate over
objects and look at the items maybe we
could add this to more things but hang
on
that's extending inbuilt methods
which is horrible and we've talked about
this for years and you shouldn't do it
so yeah all right let's let's talk about
that let's have a quick history lesson
and when i talk about history
i mean probably two weeks ago uh chrome
added the es6 array find sugar js
had a fight with es6 array finding
chrome
uh sugar js broke in chrome everywhere
um you know it's i've always liked the
idea of sugar js i've just
avoided it precisely for that reason
so yes this is this is it started with
prototype
but it's it's still going on now this
kind of argument
so in es3 there's a couple of reasons
why we don't generally extend inbuilt
methods in javascript while we haven't
in the past
first is that whenever we add a method
here is a boring old style method
attached to object prototype uh they
appear
in iteration so we have some objects
which actually doesn't have any keys in
it
when we log each key obviously the
method is going
to appear maybe not so obviously but
yeah methods appear as keys in objects
it's annoying and it's what you don't
want now there was a fix for this
oh actually before i talk about that
do notice that objects still have
methods on them in es3 each object has
to string for example
but you've never seen to string when you
iterate over the keys in an object
uh you know yeah tostring exists
it's native code it's the things that
are built into
our environments um don't actually
appear in for loops
so the problem specifically is that
added methods are always enumerable in
es3
they always appear in for loops there
was a fix to this
what the prototype guys say and what the
sugar guy well prototype guys
said and what the sugar guys say
uh is if you if the entire universe
changes the way they do for loops
to only iterate over uh properties that
are on the object
rather than inherited from their parents
um
then this will be fixed because you're
not going to get anything from object
prototype if you're iterating over just
the things on an individual object
that is technically true but oddly
enough the entire universe has not
changed
uh so has a uh
uh so has own property is is not an
ideal fixed
extending prototypes in es3 is risky
because you will get libraries from
other people
and they will just use standard for
loops why because they don't want to
make allowances for you
es5 is a little bit different um this
isn't shimmable
so you won't get it in es5 shim you you
it
you can't fake it in ie8
um whatever you uh you can there's
object defined
property one of the uh the things there
is we have this enumerable false
um when we actually create methods on
uh when we create methods on prototypes
we can tell uh we can tell es5
that that method will never show up on
that prototype
if we log the keys in the object our new
style method which we've given it here
which is boring and empty will never
show up
that's cool so
the uh yeah the iteration issue is
solved if you don't have to support an
es3 browser
and you add prototypes and you do it
using object define property
specify a numeral numerable equals false
and
your regular old for loops will work
just fine
but that's not the only problem with
extending methods
um people pick generic names so
string.prototype.namespace was a fight
between
jquery and sugar array.prototype.find
was a fight between
chrome and sugar and es6 and sugar
there was a whole bunch of other stuff
with prototype before that
so why not not pick generic names
uh do you think year six committee is
about to turn around and start naming
things after you or your company
set a sensible prefix so
thinking about this and thinking right
now there's a little bit of a hole in
kind of the community here we have
two main common method extension
mechanisms we have underscore where
methods aren't actually on the object
you expect they're on an underscore
so it's not quite so pretty to look at
but
it uses regular for loops it's
conflict-free it's totally stable it's
got a great history
sugar is really nice and pretty to look
at but
they expect the whole universe to change
their for loops
and that they have a bad history
so keeping in mind that the es5 gives us
the ability
to use defined property and have
non-innumerable methods
and that we could probably do make some
effort towards
making prefixing better and perhaps be
user selectable
i made something it's only for as5 those
other two libraries have to support ia8
so
they can make compromises that i don't
have to make um
and it's a this idea was lightweight
sugar
it's methods regular for loops it's
conflict-free
it's actually been used in production uh
at my old employer bizarre voice
since early 2012 uh in the time
all the liaison stuff that went into
chrome et cetera
all the other stuff that's happened that
has affected things like sugar
zero of those things have affected agave
um i'm going to do a quick little demo
of that as well
so
um this is a really common this is
actually probably one of the first
things i actually added to agave um
i do as i said before a lot of stuff
that kind of sits between the github api
and the amazon api has anyone used the
amazon api
cool aws lib or the native one or
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
it's if you've looked at the api
responses from amazon
they are awful i think they're actually
converted xml so you have like
results actual results nested under that
and then like items nested under that
and then like actual items nested under
that it is nasty
so sometimes rest apis have a really
contrived and long paths
something useful is there but finding it
can totally suck and that's a bummer
um so for reject js 2003
uh you know we've run we've imported
agave and run enable with rj
rj for reject we could have used reject
if i was
if this is a personal project i probably
would use rj because it's nice and easy
to type
if it's something i'm releasing to the
wider world i'm going to pick something
longer
to avoid conflicts i'm probably going to
pick like reject js just to be
more precise about it um obviously
obviously iterating works fine we don't
have any
anything from agave appearing
in in
our iteration and you can see that if we
do
look at the keys in our objects so
object dot keys will do the same thing
we have just the the keys going down the
left
some rest apis really suck not looking
at anyone but amazon
but we can still run mock object rj get
path
get path being the method name rj being
the prefix we enable the agave with
really long paths that being a key name
in that huge
amazon api response and we'll actually
get whatever was located underneath that
key
this is way more readable and usable and
having punctuation everywhere we don't
you know it's if we
are living in an es5 only world we don't
have to make those compromises anymore
um yeah but don't just take my word for
it i mean
there's two issues there's the define
property thing there's generic
namespaces
there's some other little stuff as well
some people don't like new methods
appearing on objects because that you
know hey windows and objects and i've
got you know
get path on window but
uh you know just deal with the fact that
windows and objects and actually having
that python window can be useful
uh you'd have to check for their
existence so this is an api response
you can't guarantee that it's going to
be shaped in any particular way
yeah yeah sorry if that wasn't obvious
um yeah you
it's amazon also do some really
interesting stuff as well where
like yeah the shape of what you will get
back will change
based on what you've called it
so other reasons well i asked brendan
ike about this
uh jquery uk in a few months back i said
hey
i live in an es5 only world and i'm
extending native objects using prefixes
what do you think about that
um because i wanted to get it from the
horse's mouth you know there's a lot of
people talking about this brett and i
ike is cool with that and that's a link
and you can click that
amber does it not a lot of people seem
to realize this amber extends prototypes
they
they have like uh different things for
strings
and array stuff uh ember extends
prototypes by
default um and you can deal without them
you can explicitly disable them they
prefer you not to do that
uh and they're actually a little bit
less conservative than i am they don't
prefix things with ember or anything
if es6 or a7 turns around and adds like
string camera lies uh string prototype
camelise
then ember may be in trouble but
yeah emma does it they're actually
they're cautious about it but
i think a degree more precaution is
actually needed hence the concept of
prefixing
the final reason is that i just gave you
a happy hippo and i work with a lot of
german people and
i understand that if you give somebody
kinder chocolate we are now friends
so thank you
the final thing i've got to show you is
just a silly experiment i probably
wouldn't use this in production but i
wanted to see if this could be done
and apparently it can um it's an
experiment in two parts
there's a data to dom binding um i
like mustache so there's this thing
called reactive that came out from the
dudes at the guardian
maybe a month ago it's just
a data binding system that uses mustache
if you understand mustache you
understand interactive
this dude's taking a photo it's an
awesome library check it out totally
independent of this talk i love reactive
it's the simplest of any data binding
system i've ever used and i
i love moustache so therefore i love
reactive um
but normally with active you have to
kind of set stuff
and uh it's not it's not live so to add
the live part
i've kind of subbed it in via object
define property
and a little bit of other magic as well
this is actually just some basic stuff
we get
we shove the data in like a little
backup thing
just so we don't recursively our get a
function doesn't recursively get itself
it's not particularly interesting it's
an experiment
we also use a prototype chain injection
which is a clever thing that kangax came
up with
that's not es5 it depends on dunder
proto
but dunder proto is being standardized
in the future so maybe that's okay
um eraser magical if you want to do
stuff when array length changes
um the prototype chain injection is
probably the neatest method i've seen
sorry i should show you a little demo so
over here i think okay so here's our
little
we have a little live bind and we just
find out
we attach our data to our demo binding
it's pretty boring
um and then we're about to change some
of our data
so right now it says hello friend you
have 28 new messages
list of things to do in berlin drink
lots of club mata
and meet friendly strangers if i
unpause the debugger we're just going to
update the data
but you'll see the dom has already
updated um
yeah it's just simply watching keys uh
and updating uh and activating the
binding when those keys change
there's a performance overhead to it but
yeah you can see we can change keys
we can do push and push works because of
the uh
clever array prototype injection stuff
yeah
it works so we can drink vodka mata meet
friendly strangers in the dark room at
barricade
and be cool and minimal and minimal cool
with richie horton
so the the guts of my talk um
and that kind of the message i want to
put out is that es5 is is coming
um you know if your current project
still needs to support i8 maybe your
next project won't your current project
might come out in 2014 how many people
will be using i8 then
2015 2016. think about the things you
can't shim
um so yeah use es5 methods directly i
love underscore
but you know javascript includes these
things now
and it's simpler and more readable just
to use them if you don't have to support
those old browsers
underscore's got a lot of other useful
stuff definitely use that but
if you need you know some array an
array.sum
use array.sum it's built into language
don't be scared to extend native
prototypes understand what you're doing
but realize that es5 gives you defined
property you should always be using that
your
prototype extensions should never be
innumerable and don't pick something
that is likely to be used by
anything else i'm not pimping agave the
reason i
wrote it is because i wanted the ability
to have a library
and have a uh allow people to pick their
own
um their own prefix for for
extended methods uh
experiment there's fun interesting stuff
originally when i saw object defined
property i'm like oh my god this is
going to be java getters and setters
that don't actually change any of the
data and just fetch it which i hate
um the yeah you can do some cool stuff
with
defined property accessors and
a prototype chain injection
thank you very much enjoy the week
you